a massive leap in the autonomous vehicle
revolution has arrived with the brand
new valid ID BLS 128 ten times more
powerful and a third the size of the
previous model it uses 128 lasers and
new auto alignment technology to map the
surrounding area with a 300 meter range
and a new study from Kyoto University's
primate research institute sheds light
on the origins of our discussed
mechanism as it turns out chimpanzees
will eat seeds from their own families
poop right away but hesitate before
eating from stranger poop Vsauce Kevin
here this is mine
after years of work by the sea setting
Institute blue frontiers is set to
unveil the world's first floating island
the island in French Polynesia will
consist of floating concrete upon which
homes offices shops restaurants and
science research centers can be built
and rearranged as needed
blue frontiers hopes to have a dozen
floating islands that can adapt to
changing sea levels ready by 2020 and to
make sustainable communities on the
ocean a viable option for 1 billion
people by 2050 researchers at Penn State
College of Medicine believe that we can
better diagnose concussions with saliva
by testing the levels of micro rna's
present in tiny molecules of spit the
team found more accurate diagnosis and
predictions of how long symptoms would
last compared to traditional survey
tools the quick reliable diagnosis of
concussions and their severity would
allow doctors and sports medicine
professionals to harness biomarkers to
implement appropriate treatment
immediately
so maybe spit analysis will be coming to
a future football sideline near you
pills with built-in radiofrequency
emitters will make sure you take your
prescriptions Brigham and Women's
Hospital did a pilot study involving
oxycodone equipped with ingestible
digital biosensors inside gelatin pills
the pills communicated information to
doctors who are able to see how often
patients use the potentially addictive
medication and these monitor patients
ended up taking only a fraction of the
prescription to manage their pain a
breakthrough that could help rein in the
growing opioid epidemic in the United
States
another new breakthrough can make
organic semiconductors a viable
alternative to silicon in phones TVs and
flexible electronics by using a new
method of doping which adds impurities
to semiconductors to increase their
conductivity researchers from Princeton
Georgia Institute of Technology in
Humboldt University in Berlin were able
to increase conductivity by 100,000
times this would allow for a cheaper and
greener way to create the foundation of
modern electronics which means that
phone in your pocket could eventually be
a carbon-based life-form kinda
buckypaper is looking to make wearable
technology cheaper researchers at the
eff amu FSU College of Engineering have
developed durable highly flexible motion
sensors using buckypaper which is a
sheet of carbon nanotubes 50,000 times
thinner than a human hair buckypaper
would allow wearable tech to stand up to
the demands of the human experience at a
fraction of the current cost everything
from bedsheets that monitor your sleep
to shoes that count your steps and track
your posture are on the table don't know
what to wear an artificial intelligence
system can learn your style and suggest
outfits a team at the University of
California San Diego worked with Adobe
to develop a trainable AI that uses your
browsing data to present images of
clothing that you'll want to put on and
it can also design new pieces of
clothing based on your preferences this
could be extremely helpful for those of
us who aren't particularly fashionable
an algorithm can now diagnose pneumonia
better than humans
pneumonia is responsible for nearly a
fifth of deaths among children under the
age of 5 worldwide and is notoriously
difficult to diagnose it took the
machine learning group just one week to
develop the checks net algorithm that
analyzes images to spot markers
indicating pneumonia after a month of
learning checks that was better and
identifying all 14 pathologies according
to the World Health Organization lower
rest
taury infections account for over five
percent of deaths worldwide a number
that checks net is poised to reduce 3d
printing silicone allows for highly
durable models with more realistic
elasticity the disney research institute
has pioneered a method of injecting a
variety of materials including water
bubbles into meta silicone prints the
result is output that mirrors the
elastic complexity of the world around
us including creating lifelike multi
density models of organs that can be
used for surgical training and bunnies
that can safely withstand hammers so
that's good for a clean and easy way to
watch every episode of mind blow I
created a mind blow website with
Squarespace I've made a lot of websites
over the years and this was by far the
most stress-free process for making a
site that looks great and works great
you just choose a template make it your
own and you're done
so check out the link below to start
creating your website in the process
support mined blood which is officially
back so I'm gonna leave you with the
Raven are the robot I do hopes will be
dancing in every living room and as
always thanks for watching
[Music]
okay mom what are you doing Susie she
wanted to hear their voice going through
the wire you can hear voices in the
water well how does it work
how'd your mother's voice get in the
phone funny I don't know I never thought
about it before we were talking as if we
were in the same room how does a
telephone work Uncle Bill no magic Susie
that science science of sound ways and
electricity
[Music]